- Hi.
- I'm Dustin.
- I'm Robin.
- Pleasure to meet you.
Is he here?
- Is who here?
(door thuds)
(accordion plays sailor music)
- Henderson!
(laughing)
Henderson!
He's back, he's back!
- I'm back, you got the job!
- I got the job!
(mimics trumpet)
Hey!
Oh!
(mimicing lightsabers)
Bleh!
(laughing)
(sighs happily)
- How many children are you friends with?
(Windows shutdown tones)
(footsteps)
- Oh yeah, yeah this'll do.
(under breath) I love you, I'm sorry.
Sorry, what the hell am I sorry for?
- Steve!
Are those for Mr. and Mrs. Wheeler?
- No.
- Good.
- Hey, what the hell?
- Do you still have that bat?
- Bat, what bat?
- The one with the nails.
- Why?
- I'll explain it on the way.
- Now?
- Now!
- I swear to God man, it's
just some little lizard, okay?
- It's not a lizard!
- How do you know?
- How do I know if it's not a lizard?
- Yeah, how do you know
if it's not just a lizard?
- Because it's face opened
up, and he ate my cat.
(growling)
(car radio playing in background)
- Alright listen kid, I swear,
if this is some sorta
Halloween prank, you're dead.
- Get outta my face.
- I don't know, I just feel like
you're tryin' way too hard, man.
- Well not everyone can have
your perfect hair, alright?
- It's not about the hair, man.
The key with girls is just,
just acting like you don't care.
- Even if you do?
- Yeah, exactly, drives 'em nuts.
Faberge.
- What?
- It's Faberge Organics.
Use the shampoo and the conditioner,
and when your hair's
damp, it's not wet, okay,
when it's damp,
- Damp.
- you do four puffs of
the Farrah Fawcett spray.
- (laughing) Farrah Fawcett spray?
- Yeah, Farrah Fawcett.
You tell anyone I just told you that,
and your ass is grass,
you're dead, Henderson.
That's good!
Just show her you don't care!
- I don't.
Why are you winking, Steve?
Stop.
(flicks lighter)
(door slams open)
Steve!
Abort, abort!
Abort!
(Demogorgons shriek)
(door slams)
(book slams)
- Okay, so this mind flamer, thing.
- Flayer, Mind Flayer.
- What does it want?
- To conquer us, basically.
It believes it's the master race.
- Like the, like the Germans.
- The Nazis?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah the Nazis.
- Hey, buddy.
Shh, shh.
It's okay, you put up a good fight.
He kicked your ass, but you
put up a good fight, buddy.
Okay? You're okay.
Okay, you're gonna keep
straight for half a mile, then--
- What's goin' on?
- Oh my god!
- They were gonna
leave you behind.
- Oh my god.
- But I promised that you'd be cool, okay?
- [Steve] Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, what's goin' on?
(screaming)
- Steve!
You're upset, I get it.
Now I know you promised Nance
that you would keep us safe.
So keep us safe.
Light her up.
(flicks lighter open)
- I'm in such deep shit.
(lighter dings)
(flames whoosh)
Here we are, so remember,
once you get in there...
- Pretend like I don't care.
- You don't care.
- I don't care.
- There you go, you're learnin',
my friend, you're learnin'.
Okay?
Now you're gonna go in there,
- Yeah?
- look like a million bucks,
- Yeah!
- And you're gonna slay 'em dead.
- Like a lion.
Grr.
- Don't do that, okay?
Good luck.
(mumbling)
- You should just speak louder!
- I intercepted a secret
Russian communication!
- Jeez, shh, yeah okay, that's
what I thought you said.
- And how do you know these Russians
are up to no good anyways?
- How does she know about the Russians?
- (mouth full) I don't know!
- You told her
about the Russians?
- It wasn't me.
- Hello, I can hear you.
Actually, I can hear everything.
You are both extremely loud.
Maybe I can help.
I'm fluent in four languages, you know.
- Russian?
- Ouyay areyay umbday.
- Oh ho ho!
- Holy shit!
- That was Pig Latin, dingus.
- Idiot.
- Now that you're outta high school,
which means you're technically an adult,
don't you think it's time you move on
from primitive constructs
such as popularity?
- Oh, primitive constructs,
that some stupid shit you
learned at Camp Know-Nothing?
- Camp Know Where, actually,
and no, it's shit I learned from life.
- Hmm.
Oh, dude!
Come on, man, not my scooper!
Oh you've gotta be kidding me.
- What?
- Anna Jacobi's talking
with that meathead Mark Lewinsky!
- Dude, if you're not gonna focus,
just give me the binoculars.
- Ah Jesus Christ, whatever
happened to standards?
- Dude, you are the worst spy
in history, you know that?
- Stop, hey!
(suspenseful 80's music)
- Hello.
- [Trainer] Everywhere
down in the loins, right?
C'mon ladies, show me what you got!
Slow now.
- No please, tell me this, and be honest.
Have you ever actually won a fight?
(grunting)
(banging)
(thunderous hit)
- Okay,
that was one time.
- Twice.
(grunting)
- Listen, that doesn't count.
- Why wouldn't it count?
'Cause it looks like he
beat the shit outta you.
Push my ass!
- What?
- Touch my butt, I don't care.
C'mon, harder!
- I'm pushing!
- (screaming) Push harder!
- Step back.
- No.
- Step back, seriously.
- No!
- Step--
(ominous chord sustaining)
- If you die, I die.
- Okay.
(whooshing)
(screaming)
(yelling)
(slam)
(grunting)
(slamming)
- Dude!
You did it!
You won a fight!
- Go, just get outta here!
What're you doing?
- Go!
- I won't forget you!
(metallic slamming)
(yelling)
(electric zapping)
(alarm sounding)
- Hey!
Henderson, that's crazy, I
was just talkin' aboutcha.
Boop!
- Steve, are you drugged?
- How many times, dad?
I don't do drugs.
It's only marijuana.
- (whispers) Whatever you
do, don't go anywhere.
- (whispers) Fine, dad.
(laughing)
- Then home, sweet home, here we come.
- Dustin?
- What?
- Yeah, we might not
wanna go to your house.
- Why?
- Well, I mighta told them your full name.
- (whispers) What is wrong with you?
- Dude, I was drugged!
- So you resist!
- Alright, where we goin'?
- Weathertop.
- Weather what?
- Just drive!
- Okay, Jesus.
(car revving)
(tires squealing)